how's everyone doing
parents only how are you doing
oh how is it that the parents were
louder than the kids kids how are you
guys doing
okay all right welcome parents
welcome parents i'm really excited to
have you here in class
um this is 3091 introduction to solid
state chemistry
and today we're gonna have a little bit
of fun uh
as you can see we got we got some
activities now
um the way i like to frame this
are there any other seats uh no not so
much
but make yourself comfortable the way i
like to frame this
is you got a lot of activities going on
already
right this is the uh parent weekend so
if we look at
um why is that happening if we look at
um the uh oh
that's not good
okay there we go um
if we look at the mit family weekend
there's activities right and so what i
thought is that
what we could do in this class we got to
learn a little bit we're going to learn
about x-rays today
but what i thought we could do is also
add
some ideas for activities that you all
could do
with your kids but it doesn't even
matter it could be with any kids
um but just you know more activities to
do
to give you more options and so in
particular i've got five suggestions for
you that we'll talk about today
the first one is staying warm right it's
gotten really cold so we're gonna talk
about staying warm
uh and then the next thing we'll do is
we'll appreciate the fall
and all the colors and we'll cook
cooking is such a wonderful thing to do
i hope you guys can do it together we'll
talk about that and we'll talk about
phones and how they crack their screens
and and we have some sort of larger
versions here
that that we'll talk about um and and of
course
it wouldn't be complete if we didn't
blow bubbles because that's a really fun
activity no matter what age you are
right so that's our plan okay that's our
plan today
now uh let's get started so we'll start
with the first activity right now
and it's staying warm okay now um
uh i so i love candles and i think a lot
of us have seen candles
um the difference
is between everyone else and your your
kids
who are in this class who see candles is
they don't see candles they see c25
age 52 combusting and
and and your kids now when they see a
candle if you guys go out to dinner and
there's a candle on the table
the first thing i guarantee you the
first thing they're going to do is
assess the volume of the room
figure out how much oxygen in grams
there is in that room
and they're going to decide which one is
the limiting reagent the candle or you
and they'll make a choice they may get
you out of the room
because you don't know right you got to
know that and of course they'll have
their periodic tables with them
at the dinner don't be surprised when
they take it out
okay now your students oh yeah that's
perfect your students also know
your kids my students your kids also
know
that a lot of the earliest chemistry
going all the way back to the times of
democritus thousands of years ago the
way it started
was because people were breaking things
and smashing things
and lighting stuff on fire and now we've
got the whole periodic table in this
class but we still
know that the most fun element of all
to light on fire is the very first it's
hydrogen
and so i thought i would show you what
that's like
okay so here's hydrogen and
like i said you know this is also
it's a way to think about the oh that's
a beautiful thing
is that a beautiful thing i got to do it
again and
and as as your kids know i could do this
a lot
but it's just it and you know now my
hand doesn't
i don't feel it because of the heat
capacity but that's another class but
what we're interested in
is is combustion is combustion right so
there's that one there too
right so this is all about the context
of staying warm
but of course right but what and you
don't need to light hydrogen on fire to
stay warm
but um but i also have suggested
discussion topics
because i don't want you just to do
these activities i want you to be
engaged
you know it might have been a while
since you guys have connected i don't
know and
and and or in person and so here maybe
you don't know what to say at first
right and so and so for example you
could talk about balancing chemical
reactions you could talk about the
concept of a mole
and you could also talk about limiting
reagents which are really really
important in life okay so that's my
first suggested
uh activity like i said we'll have uh
you know five new activities that's the
first one
but like i also said we got to learn
something today and uh
students this is not on the exam as a
reminder but we do need to learn
what x-rays are because next week we're
going to be shining them on stuff
so today we're going to learn about how
x-rays are generated
um and and it all starts with the very
first selfie
this is it does anybody know who that is
that
is anna renkin that is the wife
of wilhelm rankin that's the very first
x-ray ever taken
okay that's the very first section i've
ever taken and wilhelm
rankin was playing around with cathode
ray tubes
and and so he i love this quote of him
he said
i did not think i investigated and
that's another now we think
of course we think but what we do in
this class is we investigate we're
explorers
we're explorers of chemistry and how
chemistry connects
to what we see in life and what we're
doing every day
right and so how did renkin do this okay
well literally it was a dark
and stormy night literally
okay and he was in the basement in his
lab
right that's him and and it's gonna be
stormy tomorrow so you guys could even
try to think about how it felt
right and and so what he did is
everybody was playing with these cathode
ray tubes everybody we learned a lot
about cathode ray tubes
right so here you put some kind of
cathode here
and then there's an anode here and you
hook it up to a voltage
okay and what happens is electrons
fly right this is a cathode ray tube so
it's a crt
electrons will fly off of the cathode
and
and go here now if they go through the
anode right and then you put a screen
here
that those are the very first cathode
ray tube experiments
and we talked about how this led to the
discovery of the electron
itself but what renkin did is he said no
hold on
what if i just sort of change so i put a
voltage here what if i amp that up
what if i just keep going right right oh
by the way there's a vacuum inside of
here
all right there has to be a vacuum and
if i am the voltage up you know what
actually i'm i'm going to put a metal
here for the anode all right
i'm going to make that some kind of
metal and i'm going to hit the metal
with the electrons
now this is exactly what happened what
happened is
um the room glowed
the room glowed so so rankin
showing in there the lights are off the
lights are off but the room was lit
and he said oh my goodness what is going
on here right what is going on
and and what he decided what he
literally
discovered a new type of ray a new type
of light ray
and because he didn't know what to call
it he didn't have a name
on that dark and stormy night he wrote
down the letter x
which he regretted later he really did
because everybody started calling he
didn't know what to call it so he called
it an x-ray
which is what happens when you do this
experiment with a very high voltage
you get rays that came off of this
and illuminated the room he said i don't
know what to call it i'll put the letter
x for now
and that stuck
now these x-rays are unique they're
unique because they have very high
energy they have very high energy so the
x-ray energies
the energies are in the range of
100 to 100 ev
to 100 kev that's a big energy
and but but we know how to go back and
forth between energy and wavelength so
we know that that means
that the wavelength range is between
0.01
and 10 nanometers and that's what's
really important you came up with a
source
that has wavelengths in this very very
special
regime this very special regime because
it's the distance between atoms
right okay now there's two types of
x-rays but
first let's let's say
at the time you might think you know
people
why wasn't he wearing anything you know
like at the dentist
why was he wearing anything they didn't
know that radiation
could be dangerous and so if you look at
the time i took a look at
you know there were ads like this for a
system to remove the hair
and it was advertised as effective safe
and painless
this is a this is a target those are
x-rays one of the first uses of x-rays
this is a a token to get into a bath
that's called a radium bath where it's a
water bath where you have radium
that you either drink or or is in the
water itself
right but and look at what's happening
in in paris
in paris radium cure a fad of paris
society
patients play bridge and take tea for
two hours daily
daily in a drying room this is what it
says
december the afternoon radium cure is
the latest craze of paris society the
popularity of the treatment new to paris
has developed quite suddenly and is due
no doubt to the fact that it is
exceedingly pleasant
oh france right
they didn't know they didn't know and it
was the same with these x-rays what is
this thing
well it turned out it was a very very
important type
of light and because of its importance
renkin won the first ever
nobel prize given in physics there's an
element number 111
named renkgenium right and 60 years
later the dna
was discovered the structure of the dna
the double helix
was was discovered because of x-rays
right so the impact of x-rays is
tremendous okay now um the next activity
as i mentioned
has to do with enjoying the fall okay
now the the thing is that um in new
england has
beautiful colors right and so if you
haven't taken a stroll
around the parks or maybe go you go up
to a nice hike
you'll see these beautiful colors
changing in the leaves
but the thing is that in our class your
kids they don't see that
anymore no they don't because when they
see colors
they think about electron levels that's
what they think about they can't help it
they cannot help it so when they see you
know orange or red all they're thinking
about is oh my goodness
there's an electron level here and an
electron getting excited and it's coming
back down and emitting a photon
and how those levels are changing as you
go from one leaf to another
and how chemistry is at the heart of it
all
right chemistry is at the heart of it
all right and and so that's what they're
thinking of and we can use chemistry i
don't know if we have
the next one ready here we can use
chemistry
not only to change the levels
of electrons that are in this material
which then changes the color of light
that comes off of it
it's all about the electrons but we can
use chemistry to control
how quickly that happens or what you
know nature does it on this kind of
yearly time scale
we can do it on any time scale because
of chemical kinetics
so we're going to get that experiment
out here in a sec
meanwhile oh there it is oh
can we give the helpers a huge hand
because they are thank you guys
okay now
all right now what do i do
and that's it it's all this is premixed
okay now this is an example of how we
can change
we can control the the color
of a material using chemistry we can
control
when do i pour it all i pour it all okay
why not yeah
okay now i want you to focus on the
larger bottle
nothing's happening keep watching it
you got to keep watching it
okay see that was that's an example but
your students your kids are seeing this
and they're saying
no it's it's all about electron levels i
got to go and write down
those electron levels i don't care if
it's a bohr model or a semiconductor
band gap i got to figure out how that
happened
how did the color change i changed the
electron levels
in the liquid that's what i did and i
controlled the kinetics so my
my my suggested topics for this one
of discussion okay chemical kinetics
now we're going to talk about chemical
kinetics later in the fall but you guys
can get a head start
this weekend right because that's what
happened there we controlled
when it didn't happen right away it
happened later
why right acids and bases also coming
later
get a head start and then how to paint
with electrons because
that is what we're doing we're changing
how electrons interact with the material
to change the color we are painting
right and that's what nature is doing
with its leaves now you might be on this
walk
and you might be strolling around and
you might not go into the countryside
you might just be down mass ave okay now
if you're walking down mass ave from
here and you go
not towards boston but the other way you
get to another school
okay now i gotta
i have i have talked to your kids about
this already
what i want to do right now is address
the parents okay
if you if you you you have activities
you're going to
right and some of them may involve i
don't know like a dinner or a party or a
lot of other parents
some of those parents may have kids
that go to the other school now
here's what i want to tell you it might
not be their fault
it might not be their fault i
we do look i i'm just saying
we do the best we can as parents we do
we do everything we can we did
everything right
and then you realize sometimes kids
have to make their own mistakes
right so i i just you know in
and and the last thing i'll say about
this you know i don't look
be nice because you know
because they're probably going through a
really hard time all right
so that's my so that's what i want to
say about the stroll
um you might wind up down there i don't
know um
okay now oh okay back to our x-rays
where were we okay now we got so x-rays
are coming off of this metal a super
high voltage is a dark and stormy night
what happened next is that
we had to figure out what were the
properties of this
light right and what we really mean
are things like intensity and wavelength
right now i wrote down
weight you know ranges there right but
basically
what you have with x-rays are two types
you have
type one type one
which is called continuous
and it arises
continuous okay
continuous and actually this is a pretty
good name because
it's a continuous energy up to a point
up to a point it's a continuous spectrum
so what do i mean by that well what i
mean by that to understand that we have
to know
how we get it there are two types of
x-rays and in this first type
what we have is we have some some atom
with a bunch of protons in there
this is this is like that metal atom and
i've shot really high energy electrons
at it
okay but that atom has electrons
sitting around it we know that one two
three four
five six seven eight okay and then again
and these are the quantum levels right
this would be
uh n equals three n equals two
and in here we got n equals one
okay but now here's the thing i'm
shooting high energy electrons at this
atom
okay well so one of the first things
that can happen is nothing at all
so if i shoot it say up here way away
you know if it's all the way up here
going way away from the atom and doesn't
feel it
then it might just come through it might
have some energy
call it e naught right and it just came
all the way through it didn't interact
that's kind of boring what if i
interacted what if i'm out here
and i interact oh i got through some of
those outer electrons
immediately what do i see if i'm a
negative charge i see this positive
charge
and i'm like ah that looks good right
it's an attraction
and so the electron curves
like that now that means that it
accelerated this is
not a bohr electron stuck in an orbit no
this one was free and it remained free
but because it got inside of the
electron cloud of the atom
it saw a positive charge and that bends
it and that accelerates it and when
something
like that's charged accelerates
it gives off a photon it gives off a
photon
so that might be some kind of energy
that it rem it has left over that we
call e1
right and and and this would be like the
photon one
right and and we know that it's lost
energy to the photon
it's decelerated it's decelerated you
decelerate
so okay so we know that e naught is
greater
than e1 but i could have shot another
one
through and this one got even luckier
this one these are my electrons incoming
electrons right these
this one got even closer to the positive
charge felt an even stronger attraction
and decelerated even more
right and and so it
also emits a photon
right and so we know that e2 must be
smaller than e1 it's
left with less energy now
what you're doing is you're decelerating
electrons by having them pass through
the the cloud of charge of an atom
and that deceleration emits photons and
you can see right away what i'm doing is
i'm kind of breaking
the electrons right well that's exactly
what this kind of radiation is called
this rate ah this radiation is in fact
called brem stralin
brim strolling
straw lung and that
literally means breaking radiation
breaking radiation okay
radiation it means breaking
well if i take this very simple picture
and
and i i try to make a plot like i said
if i want to understand my light i got
to know about like
how it behaves as a function of say
wavelength or frequency
right and so if you plotted
the wavelength with the intensity
well you can see right here i'm going to
get okay so i'm going to get
uh some photon that comes out that has
some
lambda right and then another photon
that comes out that has another lambda
but you can see that that electron could
have been
could have been breaked at any
loss of energy right at any loss of
energy and so what you get
is something that is very continuous
oh to a point this is the shape that it
looks like right
so i can get this is right lambda right
okay so
if lambda is out there this would be
like lower
energy lower energy photons
and now up here it's higher right higher
energy photons okay
now these are all x-rays they they're in
this very high energy
range but you've got this continuous
spectrum
because the electron could have been
slowed down in any way
except higher than this point
why well that's just determined
by how much energy that initial electron
got because you can imagine
this point is a kind of special point
right this
is a this represents a fully
stopped electron fully braked
fully stopped electron so that incoming
electron has transferred
all of its energy to the photon and
that's because this is higher energy
that's as high as it gets that makes
sense right
okay we have a name for that too that's
the dwayne hunts limit
dwayne hunt limit
and basically it says that the energy
of the maximum energy
e max of the
of the the photon that can come out is
equal
to the electron times the voltage right
the charge of the electron times the
voltage across
ev right across the tube and that that
is equal to
hc over lambda min
this is just saying max energy equals hc
over min wavelength
energy wavelength right
okay so that's one time and if i had but
now you can see if i shot it
now i'm bumping up the voltage even more
and i'm shooting it with higher energy
electrons well you can imagine that if
if the if the electrons i shoot in
have a higher energy then that point
is going to go in and in
like that all right so this would be
brem strolling radiation and this would
be
increase increasing incident
oh ink ink that's not good incident
right electron energy
and i will put a box around this so that
it's
increasing right
is that arrow going like that so if i
shoot it with higher and higher energy
electrons
i'm still going to have a minimum lambda
but it's going to get smaller and
smaller
continuous x-rays okay
that's type one now speaking of
breaking now speaking of breaking
okay now here's my third activity
and it's cooking and i love cooking and
i hope you do too it's a really fun
thing to do
and i think that you know i love cooking
with cast iron
so maybe you've got a piece of cast iron
in your in your dorm
that you could pull out and and pull out
a recipe
and start making something yeah but what
i want you to think about
see and this is the thing is your kids
our students don't see it as
cast iron anymore they see it as iron
with interstitially doped carbon
that's what they see it as right
and and so and so i want you to see it
that way too and then that
just gets you thinking how is this cast
iron so strong
and oh wait the early chemists i heard
they they smashed and they
and they and they lit things on fire how
how could we break this cast iron could
it break
could it break is there you know should
we be worried about it
and so what i think you should do oh
yeah there it is let's take this
is you take the uh i don't have a pan
but i have this
is this filled yes okay and
and you take out a hammer because you
have a hammer in the closet
right and you go like this and and
nothing happens and then you do it again
okay you say well you know what maybe we
need
to go a little bigger and you go into
your closet
and you find the sledgehammer and you
say you know what
i think if we just use this handy
sledgehammer
hopefully not in your dorm um then maybe
we'll break it and so you
you keep hitting it not over the
electrical
and you eat it again and i won't i won't
use
i won't go extreme here but i will tell
you that i've done it before
um it's and and nothing happens nothing
happens there's not even a scratch on it
yeah so but many but these are your
these are your kids who go to mit
not another school and they know and
they know
that intermolecular forces have power
they've got a lot of power and they know
about bonding and they know about the
hydrogen bond
and the power of the hydrogen bond and
how strong it is and why it is
and then they start thinking about water
so i wonder if we could leverage
the power of the hydrogen bond now do we
have
liquid nitrogen we do okay
so you know so i think they put it
together that
we might be able to leverage that power
of the hydrogen they knew they saw the
gecko they say the
london dispersion lets a gecko climb a
wall
well then hydrogen bonds might be what
it takes to break the cast
iron right all the all that you need is
to pull
the liquid nitrogen out of your dorm
closet
and and yeah okay
you want to go ahead yeah
okay and and and and you know fill it
with water
and then because you need to take
advantage of the power of the hydrogen
bond
and then uh and then let it sit of of
course with the blast shield
that you also have handy right
um okay well let's see how this goes
and we might take a we'll see what
happens
it's uh uh again this okay this is a
bonding moment
right this is a bond this is a hydrogen
bonding moment
but this is where the two of you the
three of you the four of you it could be
a huge group
this is where you talk about things like
the crystal structure of iron right this
is where
you talk about things like
intermolecular forces and we've learned
in the mall
we've learned about them all in this
class where you talk about the power of
hydrogen bonds
and the power of the bond between you as
a family
right this is it just do it on this side
of
of the blast shield
okay now we'll let that sit we'll see
we'll see how that goes
um and okay
yeah that's good now uh okay now where
were we oh
so uh right oh there's another type of
x-ray there's another type of x-ray
and and the other type of x-ray
that's the only board left
okay the other type of x-ray
is is from
a different phenomenon that also has
to do with
it also has to do with the atom and the
electron
because the one type is because the
electrons are coming through this cloud
and they get a little attracted and they
lose energy and they give that off to an
x-ray photon but see the other kind
comes
from a direct excitation the same kind
that we learned about when we looked at
the bore atom
right and so so this is drawn here now
there's a very important thing that
happens
as we've learned in this class when you
go from one kind of
area of expertise to another like
crystallographers don't like commas
they don't like commas don't upset a
crystallographer it makes no sense it's
not worth it this is
the same thing with x-ray specialists
don't
use n equals one n equals two and equals
three
use klm because they prefer that so so
the klms there are simply the quantum
numbers the principal quantum numbers
right so so 1 is k
2 is l and 3
is m and all we're doing is the same
kind of excitations it's drawn there
very well
right so you see the incident electron
comes in and now it's got enough energy
to excite one of those core electrons
it's got enough energy to excite it
and so what it does is it trades energy
with that core electron the core
electron goes up and then it comes back
down now if we had say
an m level so this is n equals
1 n equals 1 2 3. so if we had
now i can draw it right if i had some
electron in my k
shell my n equals one shell and and that
electron got bumped up
to an l shell well now you know
from our work with the bore atom right
you know that when this goes back down
it's going to emit
a photon right right but this is very
different now
this is very different this photon has
only that energy
nothing in between it's not continuous
i'm getting used to wearing this
it feels good feels pretty good
okay well but so so now
i could have had an electron instead of
go to the l level
maybe it went all the way up to the end
level and then from there
it went it cascades back down and it
emits a photon
right and the way this works in terms of
labeling is
because it goes down to the k level
these are k photons and we go in order
so
so this is the least energy k photon it
ended in k
so that's a k alpha k
alpha alpha
okay or k uh
i'll just write it out to be clear k
beta
oh i hear sizzling oh that's because
you're pouring
that's good yeah more liquid nitrogen
is never a bad thing no that's great
no no i'm good you guys are doing such a
good job now um
okay so if it's k beta because it went
to k it ended at k
it gave off a photon the photon is is
either alpha beta
right gamma depending on which one but
now okay uh here's the thing
you know if you go back to that plot of
energy right of lambda versus intensity
well you know that there's nothing in
between there are no electronic
states in here so you can't excite in
between
this is forbidden it's forbidden so
unlike the breaking kind
of radiation in this case it's very very
discrete
right and so now if we plot what you get
from this well you're going to get a k
alpha peak that's very very discrete and
you're going to get a k beta
peak that's only at the one
the one energy that is the difference
between these levels
k alpha k beta so that's another kind
this is a type two
type this is type second type
second type of x-ray
okay i mean it sounded interesting
we'll let it keep going we'll let it
keep going
it's good because it gives you a time
and i hope oh you guys can just
leave it i i hope that you know during
this time that you're
you're doing these activities don't have
your phones
you know put them down listen to the
sounds of
of cast iron popping you can't
appreciate it if you're on your phone
tweeting it or or dm'ing it
you can't do that it's not going to
happen it won't be as much of a bond
right so did i get it right no
oh okay now okay so so we've got our
second type of x-ray and it's discrete
and we're going to put them together in
a minute
um but first we got to talk about glass
now
oh more okay good
good keep going just walk over
oh glass that's perfect now the only way
okay the thing is that um
a lot of times this happens to your
phone and and
we know about crystals in this class and
this is the one
if you're willing to pay hundreds of
dollars of more more for your iwatch you
can get a quartz
uh screen this is quartz this is what we
know now we don't look at the apple ad
we look at this
in this class i'm good we're good
yeah thank you and so we can hand this
out and and
because we like to touch and feel the
chemistry in this class
that is quartz that is quartz that's not
glass
by the way and that's another thing
we're going to learn
right glass means amorphous
it means not crystalline it means not
crystalline that's the thing on the
right
now quartz has has a lot of really great
properties very strong material
but it's a lot more expensive which is
why this happens and you got all this
all this glass this amorphous sio2
that is uh oh that was a good one
now yeah i see water coming out um
and and so and but there are ways to try
to make that
stronger right to try to make the
amorphous s out too stronger
and there's no better way to think about
that i don't want you to break your
phone
right but if you think speaking of
phones
but if you think about glass you you're
probably thinking about baseball
and if you think about baseball you're
thinking about the red sox of course
right am i right and and um
and so i brought glass and i and i want
to think about how glass breaks that's
what we're going to study
in a couple of weeks in this class but i
thought let's bring this to life but i
need some volunteers and i'd like some
parents to come down
i need some baseball arms some people
who can who can
throw this at the glass it's okay come
on i need some volunteers come on
there you go okay you don't look quite
like a parent but it's okay
all right now okay now
okay now oh okay now we need to get
let's get you a little further back
and um we're gonna have you put this on
okay this is for aim and now what i want
you to try to do
is throw this as hard as you can at that
piece of glass on the left
okay can you do that all right we really
let it go
now hold on hold on so let's let's move
you right over here
the one on the left right there as hard
as you can
okay that's all right try it again we
get multiple tries here
we'll take turns we'll take turns okay
try again
okay that was good i think we need try
it a little harder one more time and
then we'll get
who what parent that's the annealed one
isn't it
that's it last year it didn't break
either
thank you very much who's next i need a
volunteer
come on down oh you look too happy not
to try
you look too happy not to try oh can you
hand those to this gentleman right here
all right come on down now we're going
after that
glas that piece of glass on the left and
we're gonna see
if it's a good piece of glass for your
phone
okay all right
let's let it rip oh yeah
that's all right try again try again
multiple tries
you got this oh
that's very strong glass try one more
time
really okay let's try the one on the
right there
let's see if that one breaks we might
have them reversed
you might have we don't have them
reversed no all right let's try that one
okay all right let's let's thank
thank you very much
now does anyone else want to try
apparently we have very unbreakable
glass maybe we've invented something new
here
at mit the sledgehammer oh
that's a great idea no right
but no but there's a reason for it
because see what we're going to learn
is that baseballs aren't the only way
even though this is boston's red sox
it's not the only way to break glass now
i don't know what's going on with this
one
um this is tempered that means that it's
been treated
now it's been treated so that it's got
super strong mechanical strength
this way right you saw that it didn't
break of course neither did that
ah but when the glass is tempered as
we'll realize it has to do with putting
certain chemistry inside the glass
ions that are bigger that cause causes
strain in the in the material that
tighten the surface
and so there's all this stress built up
and it's all at the very edge
right so this part is super super strong
but this part just a simple little tap
i didn't even i barely even touched it
right and and so
so that is
now um so the moral of that story is
um glass might be stronger than you
think i guess
uh in this one and also don't tap the
edges of glass
especially if it's tempered because
that's what makes it so tough on this
on the surface right but the strain
builds up and if you relieve it with
just a tiny little tap
boom right okay now
all right oh where were we okay now uh
okay oh discussion topics
uh crystal versus glass okay ordered
versus disorder
substitutional dopits that's how you
temper glass right that's what's in your
iphone glass
and of course the red sox on tonight
right and you should watch game three
now the thing about these peaks is that
um
these are these peaks these are called
characteristic and what's nice about
them
is in fact that no matter what they only
depend
i don't care how much energy i send in
these peaks only depend
on the metal atom right so rent can put
in
a metal and you'd always get the same
peaks if i give it enough energy
right maybe i don't have enough energy
to excite anything from down here
you don't get these peaks you still get
grim strolling but you don't get
characteristic uh peaks they're called
characteristic because they're
characteristic of the metal
now they're dependent on the chemistry
if i put a different metal in i'm going
to get different peaks
right and so with these two types of
x-rays
i've got a new kind of light that i can
shine on materials
right i've got a new kind of light that
i can shine and the light
when i plot it all together it might
look something
like this
right where maybe these maybe these are
are the peaks the the oh okay
maybe these are the peaks due to going
down to k
and these are the ones due to going down
to l right so those are k
and these are l right
and the rest is continuous and they're
on top of each other and i get it all
but with that new kind of light i can do
new things and that's very important and
that's what we're going to do
after the exam which is on monday
the exam don't forget about the exam
when you're doing all these activities
you've got to think about the exam
why is this important this is important
because
we will be shining x-rays as a source of
light
onto crystals and there's a very
important thing that happened
that happens when you shine light onto
something and you can see it here
light is a wave light is a particle
light is a wave light is a particle have
that discussion too
but here we're looking at it as a wave
and waves diffract
that means that they can add or or
cancel each other
right like water waves but depends on
the size of the thing they're
interacting with if the size of the
thing they're interacting with is the
same
as the wavelength of light then you can
get diffraction pattern
and so when we shine x-rays which are
the
which have wavelengths that are the same
as the spacing between planes in a
crystal
right well then it interacts and it can
diffract
and that allows us to determine the
structure
of the crystal that's called x-ray
diffraction and
and this is this is how it all started
it started with the bragg
uh father and son pair who actually said
in their paper the crystal is in fact
acting as a diffraction-graded grating
right and from that you can literally
tell us which kind of crystal it is
i want to point something out here okay
um
that's a father and son they both won
the nobel prize
together for this discovery now i'm not
putting pressure on
on you guys i'm just saying it's not all
about the kids
right it's the parents got to step up
too
okay so that's brag diffraction and that
is
one of the most x-ray diffraction this
is what we're going to do with these
these powerful sources of light this is
one of the most important ways to
characterize crystals um that we have
and and just as a reminder oh i
mentioned the exam you know
don't forget this is what we're talking
about these planes
oh notice the negative right remember
the one one one one bar don't forget
about negative directions
right these are the things that we're
diffracting off of literally
the crystal planes so just a reminder
not to forget about
that but i can't end i can't end by
talking about exam one
so i have to end with something happy
and bubbles always make us happy
always right i love blowing bubbles i
always will i always have
and so but we don't just blow bubbles in
this class we don't just blow bubbles
we we really blow bubbles
right and so what we're going to do
is we're going to show you how we like
to blow bubbles you want to do this
you go ahead all right now what we like
to do is we like to really blow bubbles
in this class
and so we're going to use exothermic
reactions
to blow bubbles and and i think that's
really a good way
um uh you you go ahead you go ahead
you're the one all right
that's the only way to blow bubbles
that's combining an exothermic reaction
with bubbles it's so good you can't get
that's happiness right there in a bottle
that is happiness that is happiness
so oh yes and look at this
success success the power
of the hydrogen bond right okay
i hope you guys have a fantastic uh
weekend
and i hope you enjoy yourselves and
follow some of these discussions
you